um
so today we're going to start lecture 19
of cs229
and the uh topics for today uh
we're going to talk about the maximum
entropy principle and how
the exponential family distributions
that we saw earlier
in the in the course can be derived from
the maximum entropy principle
and we will show how you know under what
conditions
maximizing entropy is equal to
maximizing the
likelihood mle and also this will kind
of uh lead us
into some interesting topics such as
calibration we'll briefly talk about
calibration and you know
what what calibration means and how it
relates to maximizing entropy etcetera
very interesting topics and then
depending on
how how how much we cover and how much
time we have left
we will talk about a few variants of the
expectation maximization algorithm
and how these variants kind of leads
itself into
some of the more recent advances in
unsupervised learning such as
variational inference and uh the
variational autoencoder
ah i'm not sure how whether we'll be
able to
finish variation auto encoders today or
even start it but
um if we don't finish it today we'll
pick it up in in the next class
all right so before we dive into today's
topics a quick recap of uh
what we covered in the previous class so
in the previous class we
covered pca and ica pca is a principal
components analysis
in pca we are given data x i
which lives in a d-dimensional space
and we are to find a lower dimensional
subspace zi
which which has uh which lives in a
space of dimension k
right for every zi we want to find its
projection on to the low dimensional
space of that we call z i and the way we
go about doing that is to map
x to x u where u is a column vector
of of k of of k columns
where each of the the column are the top
k eigen vectors of x transpose x
right and by by ah
by uh doing this operation we
effectively ah get the projections
on to this uh subspace
um and then we talked about independent
components analysis
in pca our goal was to find a low
dimensional subspace whereas in ica our
goals are very different
in ica our goal is to find independent
sources that explain our data
and the assumption that we made where
there are d different independent
sources
we call them s j where j
indexes the source number so the each of
the s js
is sampled from some probability
distribution ps which has to be
non-gaussian
you can either use you know the laplace
distribution or the
the logistic distribution any
distribution which is kind of
has mean 0 and it's non gaussian we saw
some intuitions of
what happens if we have gaussian if you
make an assumption about gaussian
distributions as being the source you
know we get this problem of
rotational invariance and so ah as long
as the sources are non-gaussian
and we have some square matrix a which
we call as the
the mixing matrix which mixes the ss
into observations so s's are unobserved
x's
are observed right and our goal is to
start with
x and recover s which are the
independent sources
and the way we want to do it is to the
relation here
we assume is that a is a square
invertible matrix
and we want to invert a to get w
and w is the matrix that we want to
estimate so that given observations we
can multiply through w and recover the
original independent sources
right and the way we go about doing that
is with maximum likelihood
where we directly estimate w and
and the and the ah we saw that
the we saw that
the probability of of uh
x can be represented in this way where
we map
x back to w uh x back to s using w
and we need a corresponding jacobian
term log
or the log determinant and
by performing this ah maximization using
gradient
ascent there is no closed form solution
for this
by performing gradient ascent we can
we can we can recover upon convergence
the
unmixing matrix w hat
right and we also saw this in the
homework hopefully you guys have
finished this question in your homework
if not no problem you know we're just
stating the results here
the the homework uh question has a small
introduction about you know um
about some explanations about kl
divergence and entropy and so on
you don't need you don't need to know
that for the purpose of this lecture but
if you've already seen it
it's helpful um so the we
define the kl divergence between two
probability distributions
right so this this is something
important right so far we've
we've seen things like uh you know the
distance between two points in a vector
space right um
here the the the two things between
which we are measuring
are probability distributions entire
distributions right so you can think of
you know p being some distribution like
this
and q being another distribution like
and we are trying to ask you know what's
kind of the difference between these two
distributions
right they're not single points but
entire distributions so the kl
divergence
from p to q is defined as uh
the expectation with respect to p of log
p by q
you should note that this is not
symmetric in the sense
the kl divergence from p to q is not the
same as from q to p
if they were the same we could have
called it a distance like here distance
but
uh it is it is uh it is not symmetric
and uh this this is the definition of of
kl divergence
this is closely related to concepts such
as entropy
so we define entropy of a probability
distribution
as as as the expectation under p
of log one over p itself so the entropy
kind of measures how spread out a
distribution is
uh so if we have a distribution
over you know some finite support
a dis a probability distribution that is
uniform over them
is considered to have high entropy right
whereas
if another distribution or the same
support
puts all its mass on any one point then
this distribution is considered to have
low entropy right
so entropy you can think of entropy as a
synonym for
uncertainty right high entropy means
high uncertainty it can it you know
you believe that the point can you know
some data observation can come from
any of these you're not you're not sure
whereas a low entropy
means low uncertainty right if this
distribution tells us that
the point that we're going to observe
next if you want to sample from this
will be from
will be this particular point alone
right there's almost zero uncertainty
there
so this is considered to have low
entropy
right and then there is also this this
ah
nice interpretation about of cross
entropy that ah that's there in the
in the homework description you can you
can see that where
we replace p over here by a different
distribution q
right and and the cross entropy is you
know gets this form expectation under p
log of one over q and the difference
between
the cross entropy and entropy
is basically actually just equal to the
kl divergence itself so the scale
divergence between
two distributions pq
is just the cross entropy minus the
entropy there are some nice
interpretations about about
this in terms of coding theory that's
there in the homework but you know
that's not really necessary for
for our lecture today as long as you
kind of uh
remember these uh these formulas
and also earlier in the lecture earlier
in the course we came across
exponential family the exponential
family is is
uh is a is a way to characterize
a family of probability distributions
where
the probability distribution over y with
some parameter called natural parameter
eta
takes this form right so here
b of y is called the base measure right
and there is the exponent of some
of of some term over here that term has
two parts
one is eta the natural parameter
dot product with t of y so t is called
the sufficient statistics over y
minus a of eta where a is called the log
partition function
right and we also saw
again in your in your homework one that
the mean of this probability
distribution
can be represented as the derivative of
the log partition function uh
so if we change eta to two different
values
we get different means and the way you
go from the parameter value eta to the
mean of the corresponding distribution
is to calculate a prime or the first
derivative of a
of first product of the log partition
function at the parameter value eta
and it so happens that this this
function a prime will always be
invertible
and so we can go from the mean of a
distribution back to
the natural parameter eta this way
right so ah the first thing we are going
to do today
is to derive maximum likelihood
estimates of eta
given some observations y and then and
then we'll jump over to maximum entropy
and and start seeing its uh equivalence
any questions on this so far
yes
so the question is um in in ica
is the log determinant acting like a
regularizer or are we going to add
regularization on top
so that's a very interesting question in
ica it so happens that most of the time
we are not really interested in
generalization error
right so ica is kind of uh in a way
different from the rest of the
algorithms that we have seen where in
the rest of the algorithms we are
interested in generalization error
whereas in ica we take some examples fit
a model
and just you know recover the sources of
the given data itself
so it's it's not common to use
regularization in ica
and this log determinant is actually not
a regularizer so this log determinant is
a necessary component to make the
distribution a valid probability
distribution
good question any other questions before
we jump into mle of exponential families
right okay so ah
mle of exponential family
so in in in the when we studied
exponential families
ah earlier in the course and when we
studied glms
we made this simplifying assumption that
y
would was always a scalar in our case so
in case of
regression y was just real values in
case of a logistic regression
y was you know a binary zero or one we
saw some
generalizations uh with soft max where y
was
would would can could take uh multiple
values
but now we're going to take an even more
generalized form where y can be you know
some some
y could be anything and t of y
which we always most of the times uh in
in when we studied glms t of y was just
taken to the identity
as y itself but now we will again relax
that and make it even more general
where t of i could be anything so
suppose
we have an exponential family
right exponential family p of y
given eta equals
b of y times exponent
i am just rewriting the same thing over
there eta
the product t of y so this is the
dot product eta can be a vector
and t of y can also be a vector of the
same dimension
right and this is just the inner product
if there if these two are scalars then
this is just a simple product
minus a of eta
right and we are given some data s
equal to y one
y small n right so we given given ah
ah this data and we want to find eta
you know ah eta hat m l e
equal to
r max so here we assume i i d
i i d right arc max
cross eta log
i equals 1 to n p of
y i it
right this is a standard you know
maximum likelihood
procedure that we followed throughout
the course there is nothing different
here
right now lets lets
simplify this further so this is
arg max with respect to eta now log of
the product is the sum of the logs
so i'm going to take the sum i equals 1
to n
1 to n and the log goes in so the log of
this
thing over here will give us
log b of y i
right plus log in the exponent cancel
get eta dot
t of y i
minus a of theta
and in order to do ah maximum likelihood
we take the derivative of this with
respect to eta set it equal to zero and
solve for
sulphur data right the same process
so for this we now take the ah
gradient with respect to eta of
this whole thing
is equal to ah so this is going to be
sum i equals 1 to n the derivative of
b of y with respect to eta is
0 right so this will be just 0 plus
the derivative of eta dot t of y i
with respect to eta will be just t of y
i plus
t of y i
minus derivative of a of eta with
respect to eta
is you just call it a prime of eta
right right
and this gives us so ah this
so we have a sum over i from one to n
of this term and we need we set this
equal to zero
this gives us n times a prime of
eta so this is n this is eta right this
is n the number of examples and this is
eta
they look kind of similar equal to
i equals one to n t of
y i r
a prime of eta is equal to one over
n i equals one to n
t of y i
this tells us
eta hat mle is equal to
a prime inverse of
one over n i equals one to n
t of y i
so what just happened here the
maximum likelihood estimate of the
natural parameter of
any probability distribution in the
exponential family
can be calculated as the the mean or the
sample mean
of the observed sufficient statistics
taken through the
the the inverse of
a prime if you remember in the
exponential family nodes we
we called g equals a prime
to be the canonical link function
and we call g inverse you know which
will be a prime
inverse to be the or i think we call
this the canonical response function
and this to be the canonical link
function
right so this is just the canonical link
so take the sample sample mean of the
observed y eyes run it through the
canonical link function and that gives
you the
maximum likelihood estimate of of eta
where this is in the most generic form
right so when we when we um when we take
specific members of the exponential
family like the poisson or the bernoulli
or you know what have you
a prime will take some particular form t
of i will take some particular form
but in the most generic in in the most
generic setting
this is the estimate for the maximum
likelihood estimate of
the natural parameter okay next question
so good question so in in the last
lecture we were doing ica
and and pca which was unsupervised
learning
so uh what's the what's the goal here
that's a very good question
so today what we are doing is uh trying
to understand this
you know a pretty generic concept called
maximum entropy principle and how that
that uh results in
in concepts such as calibration and kl
divergence
and we will use scale divergence as a
concept to
uh kind of uh uh
understand variational inference and
variation auto and auto encoders
so uh this i would not call it either
supervised or unsupervised because these
are just
uh you know maximum likelihood estimates
about of you know general probability
distributions
this has um yeah i wouldn't call this
either supervised or unsupervised these
are just exponential family
distributions
good question all right so this was the
maximum likelihood estimate of of
the natural parameter and let us just
save it because we will refer to this in
a shortly in a few minutes
now
let's switch gears and
talk about maximum entropy right so in
um
so the maximum entropy principle is a
principle that tells us that
whenever we want to estimate a
probability distribution
with some observed data
let's suppose we have a probability you
know
probability distribution over the real
values
right so the the ah
this is r and
x and this is p of x right
so ah and suppose we make some
observations
on x in right so we observe this we
observe this and we observe this as
samples from
this probability distribution and our
goal is to now
estimate you know what the density of
what p of x is
right and given just three points
it's very hard to tell you know what the
density of
of a p of x is right ideally what we
would like to have
is you know an uh infinite number of
observations
you know preferably in an uncountably
infinite number of observations
so that we can precisely calculate the
fraction at each point and and construct
some kind of a density right but we are
only given
um a finite number of points uh
you know they could be large they could
be small but we are still given a finite
number of points
and we need to estimate the value of p
of x at every
point x and the maximum entropy
principle
tells us that the way we want to go
about it
is to first translate these data points
into constraints right so for example ah
the mean of this these set of points
could be
you know say mu hat right so mu hat
you know is just the sample mean
right similarly the the variance
could be
n equals 1 to n
x i minus
mu square right so this is just the the
ah
and if if we take this r to the mu hat
this the sample uh
standard deviation right and the
maximum entropy principle tells us that
the
uh our estimate for p of x
should be a probability distribution
that is
subject to these constraints and these
are hard constraints
and within the family of probability
distributions that satisfy these
constraints
choose the one that has the highest
entropy
right so the constraints we can call
these constraints
right the the constraints
define a set of all probability
distributions
that are what is also called as feasible
right any probability distribution that
that satisfies these
is a feasible candidate for our estimate
and then among this um large set of
feasible probability distributions the
feasible probability distribution will
almost certainly
uh you know be more than one you know
because there are an infinite number of
probability distribution that satisfy in
this example
a particular mean and and standard
deviation among the set of all
uh feasible distributions choose the one
that has the highest entropy that's what
the maximum entropy principle tells us
and the way we go about formulating it
is
the way we go about formulating it is um
p which is the estimated probability
distribution over y
to clarify some notations ah let us call
this y
and you know we'll be using y instead of
x
right so p is equal to
r max overall p
maybe we can just call it p star arc max
overall piece
which maximizes h of p
which is the entropy right h of p is
just the entropy that we define here
such that we have some constraints
so the constraints we will write them in
the form
ah we will limit ourselves to linear
constraints by linear constraints what i
mean is
such that sum over
sum over j
or the sum over i t
j of p
i is equal to some c i what does that
mean
so we will assume that the constraints
for our estimation problem are given in
the form of some
functions t's which are indexed by
j yeah ts are indexed by j
so t is some function that takes y
to r right so
ah the the constraints that we are given
you know ah constraints such as these
will be given in the form of these ah
these t functions where we have
n such things
or m such things so uh j equals 1
through m t j of
of y to r what does this exactly mean it
means
that for every corresponding
tj there is a corresponding cj the
constraint value
where we need to satisfy sum over
i equals 1 through n t
t i j t
t j of y i
is equal to c i now if
t j if if for example one particular t
ah of y if we consider this is equal to
just
y itself then this gives us
a constraint for the mean
because this basically boils down to i
equals one through n
t of
y times
i i also forgot p of i t of y
times p of y is equal to c i
c s c so this is just
if if t of y is equal to just y then
this becomes
i equals 1 through n y times p
of y is equal to the expectation
of y right so for different choices of
ts
or rather the different choice of
sufficient statistics we
we can express constraints in this form
and
we are also going to assume that the
support
of y is finite
right this support uh for white uh being
finite
is uh is a simplifying assumption
and we don't really need this uh
to show to show uh the results but we're
gonna
assume it is finite so that we can
represent things as you know inner
products and sums rather than integrals
right and we assume that n is the
kind of size of the set y
this was the question
so how can there be other kinds of
constraints so generally the constraints
are are uh constraints given
are of the form where the you know some
kind of a moment
of the observed uh data is equal to some
value right so
the moments of the distribution should
match you know some the moments of the
observed
samples generally those are the kind of
constraints we are interested in
why don't we directly use these
constraints because we can just take the
form of our exponential family and then
using these constraints try to make
constraints on the parameters b
and data well so when we are so so the
question is why don't we start with here
so the the exercise that we are trying
to
uh do right now is to start from uh
p from the maximum entropy principle
make no assumptions about the form of p
right here so far you know p could be
any kind of a probability distribution
we are just assuming some kind of a
support
and what we are going to show is the
maximum entropy principle will recover
the exponential family
that's that's our goal over here right
and intentionally we are
using the same symbols you know t's and
y's
that are going to end up being you know
the corresponding terms in in
the exponential family so um the
the the t's over here are trying to
satisfy some constraint
right eventually you know by the end of
this exercise we will see that t's will
be the sufficient statistics
um but for now you know just assume t's
are are
you know some kind of a function
whose linear combination with p must
satisfy a constraint value
right so we have
so n is the n is the
the cardinality of the set y and we have
m constraints
right which means
we have m such t functions
and now our task is to perform this
optimization
right so we want to maximize the entropy
of the probability distribution such
that
um some kind of linear constraints over
p
are
are are satisfied so ah so
this let me write this
more clearly
i t of
y i j times
p of i is equal to c of
j where j equals 1 through
m so there are m such t functions
and all these t functions must satisfy
this
this kind of a constraint where the
expectation of t
is equal to some constraint value c and
most of the times these constraints
will be arising from data from the
observed data
right where c j will be equal to
ah
will be equal to one over n
where n is the number of examples i
equals 1 through
n t of
y i j yes what's the question
right below so there's an i
after you know the y bracket there's an
i over the y oh oh oh yeah you're right
so
thank you so this is so so yeah so to
uh to to
clarify the notations there are m such t
functions
and each of those m is indexed by j
right
and t j tells us you know it's the jth
t function and i is the
i is the index we use to scan the
support of
y right so y there are there are
capital n elements in y and
i equals 1 through n t of y i so every
possible value of i
will get a probability of p i
that's the probability of of ah so
p i is equal to p of y i
right so we're going to switch you know
it's it's very common that
you know we switch between uh the the
functional notation and the vector
notation
right they mean the same thing
so we are given a set of linear
constraints
and satisfying these linear constraints
we want to maximize the entropy yes
question
oh sorry yes
basically each individual data point
that we have yeah so a question so what
is the support of y
so here we are assuming y is has finite
support which means
y can take on a finite number of values
right so y itself can live in a high
dimensional space but we assume
y can take on a finite number of values
right and p of y i tells us the
probability
that our distribution assigns to that
point y i
our observed y i's y superscript
you know parenthesis i are the actual
observations
so why superscript i tells us what the
observation was right if you
sample many of them but each of these y
i's
will be one of the finite numbers of
elements in script y
okay
exactly so this is just a way of saying
that we are only interested in discrete
distributions
uh we would uh a compact support over y
uh so so for example so for continuous
this could be the entire r line
real valued line it should yeah
all right uh any any any questions in
this let me repeat it there were a few
uh uh typos so just just to uh um
just to repeat it so that everything is
clear we
right so so we we we ah we assume that
y has finite support which means there
are n
n is the size of the cardinality of
script y
right and our probability distributions
are assigned over the space
now we are given some observations small
n number of observations of y
i's and out of these observations we can
construct constraints
right so the constraints can be for
example
that the mean of the observed data
has some particular mean it could be
that
the um the the square the sum of the
squares of the observations
is you know some value that could be
another constraint it could be the sum
of the cubes of the observed values
is some value that could be another
constraint right
so t of y can be things like you know a
t of y equals y t of y equals y square
they are there are different possible uh
functions of y and out of the
those functions we construct these
constraints
that uh the uh this constraint basically
tells us that
the mean of of the distribution p
will have to be the mean of the
of the t function of a particular
a t function should be you know some
particular value and so on
right now subject to these constraints
now we want to solve
this optimization problem the way we go
about solving this problem
is to construct what is called the
lagrangian
so if t the the the t function is if
that is still a little confusing
you can assume t to be uh to generally
take on two values the most common
values for t
are t of y equals y and t of y equals y
square those are like the most common
kind of constraints that we come up with
where we want to say the mean is
something
the you know the first moment is some
particular value and the second moment
is some some particular value
but here we are trying to derive it in
the most general form where t could be
anything
and so using these constraints and the
entropy objective
we will construct the lagrangian
so the lagrangian l of
p eta
and lambda so this is the
uh probability uh the variable for the
probability
distribution itself and eta and lambda
are
lagrange multipliers
and the lagrangian will be h of p
plus the inner product of eta
comma t p minus c
plus lambda times
inner product of 1
p minus 1. what is this
so here p
is our probability distribution you can
think of p
as you know p 1 p 2
p n where
n is the cardinality of the set y and
t is a matrix where
we have you know t one a row
corresponding to t one so that would be
t one of y one
t one of y 2
t 1 of y capital n
and similarly we have m such
so t m of y 1
t m of y2 t
m of yn
so this is small m the number of
constraints
times n n is the cardinality of y
and this is n
and our our constraints say that you
know the inner product of this
with this should be equal to c
1 until c n
right so this matrix times this vector
equals this
vector is capturing the set of all
constraints
under which we want to operate right
so this inner product is like the
expectation so
each
each row times a column
is basically the expectation under p
of t
t 1 of y
expectation under p d
2 of y
expectation p
t n y right
so this vector
is equal to
c one through c n
right so these two are
equivalent ways of of of writing yes
question
so the question is t's and the c's are
the constraints that we choose to impose
that's correct
and the c values are generally evaluated
from data
right so given some data we we see what
the empirical values
of of uh the uh the c's are and make
that the constraints
what is p so p is the probability
distribution itself that we are trying
to estimate
right so p must satisfy p
i is greater than equal to 0 and sum
p i i equals 1 to n should be equal to 1
right so p is the probability vector
that we are trying to estimate
and the way we want to estimate p is
such that it it
maximizes the entropy and satisfies
these constraints
so is is p2 the number of times you
observe
y2 in all of your ys in the long running
average
yes the number of times we we will
observe y
uh y2 across all wise
so p2 is just the probability of of y2
now think of p2 as
equal to of pythagorean
we're going to talk about only you know
point values of c's
right right and so this
is the set of constraints right
so t p minus c is the is the
set of constraint that should be equal
to zero and
this basically tells us so now this is
the
entropy that we want to maximize
this is for the
constraints you know from data
generally right and this is
to make to make
p a valid ah
valid probability distribution
right so we construct this lagrangian
and we we pretty much just you know
solve this optimization problem from
this lagrangian
right so to solve this lagrangian we do
first we ah start with
taking the derivative of the lagrangian
with respect to ps
and we get partial
of partial with respect to p i
of the lagrangian and this is equal to
partial partial with respect to p i
of h of p
plus eta times
t b minus c
plus lambda
times 1 p minus 1
right and now we
differentiate this with respect to p i
so h of p
i is sum over all
sum over i p of i times log p of
i right so all the terms
except uh the i term can be
eliminated so p
i this will be minus p
i log p i we are ignoring the non
i terms because they're going to you
know cancel with with
a pi anyways plus
t p minus c lambda
1 p minus 1
right and when we take the derivative
what we get is uh apply the product rule
taking the derivative of this with
respect to p i first we differentiate
the first term
times the second term and then we
differentiate the second term times the
first term
so that will give us minus
log p i
plus the derivative of log p is just 1
over pi 1 over
t p i times pi is just 1
plus this will be just the inner product
of eta
times t of
y i
plus lambda
right so ah
what what what we are doing is when we
are in this in this
in this expression which is basically t
p minus c
p i will appear only in the in the
ith column here right
so this ends up being eta and
c will just cancel will get cancelled
with with p i so this will be just the
inner product of eta
with t of y i
and from this we basically get that ah
we want to take this derivative and
set it equal to 0 which means
we get you know take ah so
log p i is equal to
lambda minus 1 plus
inner product of eta times
t of y i
and this gives us p i
is equal to e to the
lambda minus 1 times
exponential of eta
right so
right away we see that p of i
seems to be taking some kind of an
exponential form
right and the the the reason why we get
this exponential form
is because in the entropy we have this
log term and when you said
log of p equals you know some value p
will be exponent
of you know some value right that's the
reason why
um you know with entropy when you're
trying to maximize entropy the presence
of this log term in the entropy will
kind of
naturally result in an exponent coming
when we solve for pi
and now
we have this and we want to solve for
lambda and solving for lambda is pretty
easy so we have p i equal to this
and sum over i equals 1 to n
p i equals 1 which means the sum
over this entire thing e to the
lambda minus one times exponent
eta times
t of y i this should be equal to one
and so e to the lambda minus 1
will be 1
over sum over y in
script y exponent
eta times t of y
right so ah we got p
to be in this form and we can eliminate
lambda by by making use of the fact
that probability distribution should sum
up to 1
and that gives e to the lambda
lambda minus 1 to be that value
and so we get the final form
of p of y to be
p of y to be so lets call this
denominator to be let us call this as z
of eta
so we get p of y is equal to exponent
of eta times t of y
divided by z of eta
where g of eta is just this normalizing
constant
and so p of y parameterized by eta
is equal to the exponent of
eta times t of y minus a of
eta where a
is just
equal to log z
right so z is called the partition
function
and a is called the log partition
function right and by taking the log we
can
bring it in ah into the term right so we
here we see that
by just ah by by just following the
maximum entropy principle
and trying to recover p where we did not
assume
any kind of form for p right we just
assume p was you know
um any any uh uh can take uh
can take any uh values subject to it
just being a valid probability
distribution
we see that by uh by having only this
constraint
maximizing the entropy of p
to satisfy the the constraints that we
observe from the data
we recover the exponential family that
ah we recover the exponential family
form for p that p of
y will always be in in the form of the
exponential family basically
yes
so this what we did here is basically
enforcing this constraint
that's what we did i'm sorry
so the question is uh should we
explicitly do this or
is it already uh you know captured in
the math so if we don't have this
constraint then
you know peace can be any you know
arbitrary value
yeah so the question is why are we
maximizing entropy
and uh there is there is a reference in
the notes that's
that's been posted which which goes into
why maximizing entropy is
kind of a natural thing to do so
basically this maximum entropy principle
has
you know has also connection with
statistical physics where
you know where the entropy has actually
the same mathematical form
and in fact there's a paper by you know
by an author his name is um in fact the
same author of the
link that's given here edwin james he
has a
an old paper called information theory
and
and statistical physics and that
basically you know
draws this nice connection between
information theory or you know the
shannon's entropy
uh the the entropy that we have here in
information theory and
you know drawing connections to the
thermodynamics entropy and statistical
physics and
both of them kind of follow the same
maximum entropy principle so it's it's
it's
uh it's kind of a natural thing to do
yes there was another question yes
so here yeah so the parameterization was
always there i just
didn't write it here
so a of eta so we we
so p of i is basically equal to
p of y i right so p of y
i is equal to this times this and
this is equal to 1 over z of eta
right so p of y is equal to this
divided by 1 over eta 1 1 over
z of eta right and z of eta
is the partition function and in place
of z
if we instead take a of a is equal to
log of z
then a will just go in into the into the
numerator
next question
yeah so maximizing the so the question
is why do you want to maximize the
entropy so maximizing the entropy you
know
um there are arguments to to uh to say
that by maximizing the entropy
we are kind of being least committal in
terms of our
assumptions which means the only
constraints that we are
enforcing is that um you know
the the the data the the observed data
that we have are the only constraints
that we are doing
any other objective if we maximize any
other objective
it can be shown that we are kind of
imposing further assumptions
that may not be you know may or may not
be
may or may not be valid in order to get
the most unbiased
estimate of p then the uh
then the right thing to do is to
maximize the entropy which means
make everything else as uncertain as
possible
subject to the only cons the observed
constraints that we have
yeah we're going to come to the link to
maximum likelihood shortly right
this question so you said uh
yeah so so the question is is is can you
think of uncertainty as the variance
the short answer is no and there are
good reasons why
variance is is not always um equivalent
to uncertainty so there is you know
there is a
link to a chapter uh in the in the notes
that's given you know chapter 11 from
the book probability theory
and that actually has some um pretty
convincing reasons why enter
variance is not the right thing to
maximize for okay
so these two are the lagrange
multipliers
these two so these two are the are the
uh terms
in the lagrangian that corresponds to
the constraints
right so one constraint is based on um
based on the the data that we have and
the other constraint is that p should
sum to one
product of one so inner product of one
and p is
so that's the inner product of the one
vector and p
the second one so the second one is you
know t of p
minus c so we want t of p equal to c
right so t of p minus c should be 0
and this is the lagrange multiplier
corresponding to that constraint
this question
yeah so so the large so the large n
corresponds to the support of the prob
of of y
and small n is the is is you can think
of it as the number of observed data
points
is the support of yes every possible y
okay so large n is the cardinality of
script y
yeah why do you take the inner product
of tp minus c
so i get that tp minus c but then like
going with the
last term shouldn't it be just some like
let's
well so uh i i'm not going to the
details of this this what what we have
here is correct if you have any more
questions you know post it on piazza i
can
i can help clarify there but you know
the
this is the correct formulation of the
lagrangian
right so so we get that
uh p of p of y will will always take
this form
where p of y which were basically the
constraints
end up being the sufficient statistics
of the uh
exponential family and
eta which was the lagrange multiplier of
our constraints
end up being the the natural parameter
of the exponential family
right and a of a uh a of eta which is
the
log partition function is essentially
the partition function that we get
by applying the valid probability
distribution constraint
right so maximum maximizing entropy
gives us the exponential family as a
natural consequence
we made no assumptions about the
functional form of p
when we started out maximizing the
entropy but
as a consequence of performing this
maximizing entropy subject to some
linear constraints
we get the exponential family as a
consequence
right so ah was there another question
yes
so the question is for any given data
set do we get a different family
so uh good question so the
the family that we end up getting is
going to depend
on the choice of the sufficient
statistics that we choose
right for a different data set we will
get different values of c's
right but the choice of the constraints
that we
that we uh chose to to enforce
will decide the family of the
exponential family
so we're going to come to estimating eta
now right
so the functional form of p
will be in the exponential family if we
start off by maximizing the entropy of p
subject to some constraints right so now
the question is
of okay so we we saw that the function
or the
the the probability distribution will
belong to the exponential family
but what about the estimates of eta
itself
so for that now let us ma
to to calculate eta so first we solve it
with respect to p
i next we will do it with respect to eta
right
so with respect to eta
of l is equal to gradient with respect
to eta
h of p is just minus sum over y
p of y log p of y
plus i am going to write this as
the inner product between eta times
t d
p minus eta times
c plus you know
lambda of something
and now we will make a few more
observations
so this is the gradient with respect to
eta
of so here this is basically
the sum over y p of
y times log p of y so
we saw that p of y has this form and
when we take the log of this
we just get the term inside the inside
the flower brackets
so it is p of y times
eta dot
t of y
minus a of eta
plus eta times
t p so what is t p we saw that t p
t p is just the expectations of the
individual
sufficient statistics so this i am going
to just write it
as expectation of p
of t of y
minus um eta
times c plus lambda of something
right so now take the derivative inside
and here we get um so this
you know uh sum over y p of y times
something is like taking the expectation
of this
eta and eta will cancel so we can write
this
as minus expect
so take the x eta out so this will be
eta
times
oh so so sorry so we still have let's
let's still keep uh the derivative with
respect to eta
so eta times expectation
of t of y
and here we are taking the expectation
of a of eta but there is no y term here
so this will just be a of eta
this is plus eta times expectation of p
of t of y minus
eta dot c plus lambda times something
right so this and this cancel so we get
with respect to theta
of a of eta minus
eta dot c
plus ah you know some some constant c uh
some you know lambda times something and
this is equal to
a prime of eta minus
c and this should be equal to zero and
this gives
us a prime of eta is equal to c
and these constraints are things that we
generally want to estimate from data
and so we get eta hat
is equal to a prime
inverse of c and that means
a prime inverse of
c which we want to be like the empirical
averages from
data so that would be 1 over n sum
i equals 1 to n t of
y i right
and this estimate
you will see is the same as this
estimate
so the last step here so from here
ah here we got that a prime of eta which
is
um a prime of eta should be equal to c
right
is it clear until the step yeah so eta
should be a prime of inverse of c
now what is c c were the constraints
that we started with
and usually these constraints come from
data right so these constraints will be
the actual
you know sample means of the
corresponding sufficient
statistics and you plug them in here
the the sample
means of the corresponding sufficient
statistics and we get
eta hat maximum entropy
maximum entropy to be equal to
the same expression that we get using
mle
so here so the question is what is t
here yes t
here is you can think of it as the
vector of you know j functions
exactly right so
what we basically got is that the
is that maximizing the
entropy subject to some constraints of
sufficient statistics that are whose
values are obtained from the data
is in fact the same gives you the same
solution
as starting off with an exponential
family
where the sufficient statistics are the
sufficient statistics
of that exponential family and
performing maximum likelihood on it
so this this ah equivalence between
between maximum likelihood and maximum
entropy
is is uh turns out to be you know one of
one of you know
one of the few interesting results uh in
this area
any any questions on this yes question
so a function will or the a prime will
always have an inverse
this question um
so a prime is the mean of the
probability distribution
and basically what we are telling is
that we want the mean
of the of the uh uh probability
distribution to be the sample mean
you know is essentially what we're
trying to say here so cis were the
were the uh means of the uh uh means of
the data so here we are trying to say
model mean equals sample mean
yeah we we got this from the maximum
entropy right so we are still
deriving the lagrangian of the maximum
entropy uh objective
and by solving for eta we we end up with
the same
estimate for uh for eta as we would have
if we had started from exponential
family directly and
chosen you know keys to be
the the subfusion statistics we are
interested in this question
here in the red box
[Music]
setting we are interested in linear
constraints that is linear in p
which means we are only interested in
you know things like moments of the data
the moments of the distribution
c's were not weighed by the pcs were
just the observed
um
that's the constraint that we want to
enforce that c1 equals
t1 y1 times p1 plus t1 y2 times p2
that's the constraint that we want to
enforce
but c1 the value of c1 itself is
estimated from data
yeah this is what you know we would
choose to
choose to seize according to this
exactly yeah all right so
so we've seen that maximizing entropy is
the same as
maximizing likelihood
and in your homework you've also seen
that maximizing likelihood
is also the same as
mle is also the same as
minimizing the kl divergence
between the sample data
and and the model
right this this is in your homework um
you know question two or three the last
subpart
ah so so ah the and this
is equal to you know max entropy
now the connection between maximizing
entropy and minimizing
here divergence is ah is also you know
called the
max and
duality theory duality theorem
right for those of you who are probably
more interested on the theoretical sides
you know then to to kind of learn more
about this duality
theorem you know you might want to look
up the maximum entropy duality here
all right now let's let's um
let's talk about uh a very related
somewhat related topic which is
calibration
right so
calibration is the problem is this
concept that
so for example when when we studied
logistic regression
we saw that the output of our logistic
regression model
was you know we we took the
inner product between x and theta where
theta was some kind of
a parameter run it through the
logistic function you know 1 over 1 plus
e to the minus x
and as the output we got a value that
was always between 0 and 1
right and we called that value
um when when we did y hat equals
one over one plus you know
exponent of minus theta transpose x
right so this will always be between
zero and one
right which superficially looks like a
probability
right because it its a value between
zero and one
but what will make it a probability
right superficially it's a value between
zero and one
and then we uh in order to use it as a
classifier we decided to use some
threshold
and you know call everything above the
threshold as positives everything below
as negatives
but what what will you know why do we
want to think of this as a probability
right so probability has has you know
has
is is is all right so let me pose a
question to you what do you think is
probability
yes
yeah so this if sum of all the y hats
equals one uh
i would still call that a a superficial
requirement for something to be a
probability
yes
exactly so the value of y should be
somehow representative
of how frequently we uh you know y hat
ends up being this
in in you know for example the data that
we have right
so ah and this this property
that ah the estimated probability values
kind of match with observed frequency of
occurrences is called calibration
right so it is
very common and highly recommended that
if you actually
build a logistic regression model that
you also
plot this calibration plot
so calibration plot will look something
like this
predicted probability
and here this is now observed
frequencies
now let us say this between 0 and 1.
take your validation set
in your validation set assume it's it's
reasonably large you know
you have a few thousand or ten thousand
examples in your validation set take
your model
and run every example in your validation
set
through your model for each example
you get a particular y hat right so you
get a
y hat and there is a corresponding
y i which is the ground truth
right now y hat will be a value between
zero and one
and y will be either zero or one
right and then your y hats will be
you know points that are distributed in
this interval between zero and one
now next you know chop this ah
interval between zero and one into say
ten bins maybe a hundred bins does not
matter
so chop it into bins
commonly you know it is ten bins but you
know it could be any number of bins
and collect the y eyes
in each bin separately or the y hat eyes
in each bin separately
right so the set of all examples that
have a y hat
in this in this that that is assigned a
value in this range
take those examples and calculate
the mean of the true labels of
all the points that fall in this bin
right and plot the the true mean of the
or the mean of the true labels
on the y axis corresponding to this bin
and ideally what you want
is to get a plot that looks like this
which means for for
all those examples that got assigned a
probability of say 0.99
we want 99 percent of them of those
examples to have the true label as
y i
for all examples that had a predicted
probability of
close to 0.5 we want the true frequency
of the labels or the frequency of the
true labels to be close to 0.5
this kind of a plot where you where you
plot the
predicted probabilities versus observed
frequencies is called a calibration plot
and if your model gives you a
calibration plot
which is a straight line then you call
your model to be well calibrated
which means the predicted the the output
y hats
from your model you can actually think
of them as probability estimates
if if this line is not a straight line
then the predicted probabilities you
cannot really think of them as
probability estimates anymore it may
still be a good classifier
right you may still be able to find a
separating threshold and assign zeros
and ones and you may get a high accuracy
but you it may not be a good probability
estimate
right so this this concept of
calibration
so calibration tells us you know
it's a statement about the quality of
y hat being
an actual probability
so if you have a model that predicts the
probability of whether it is going to
rain tomorrow
and take the and you run it every day
and you have a few thousand days of
predictions right
now take the set of all uh
examples or the set of all days where
the predicted next day probability rain
was say 80 percent
and then look at the data and see what
fraction of those days
did it actually rain if your model is
well calibrated then the fraction of
days that it rained the next day
should be approximately 80 it shouldn't
be 90 it shouldn't be 70 it should be 80
for it to be well calibrated
next question two questions
secondly if it is not
you know a 45 degree line what can you
do to solve it
yeah so uh good questions so uh
if all we care about is a good
classifier then why do we care whether
you know the predicted
uh y hat is a is a valid probability or
not and the reason is because
whenever you're making building a
machine learning model that predicts
something into the future
it is it is most of the times
you know you you don't really want a
binary answer from a model you actually
do want some kind of an uncertainty
estimate coming out of the model which
means you actually care
you know how certain is your model about
this prediction into the future
if it has a prediction you know say yes
you know 51
probability that it's going to rain
versus another
you know a situation where it gives you
a 97
probability that it's going to rain you
want to kind of treat those two
predictions
you know differently if you just think
of it as a classifier both of them will
be classified as
y equals one right but uh but when
you're
when you're trying to make decisions
about about you know about the future or
in general
you you know many times you actually
want this uncertainty estimate as well
right and uh what do we do if it is not
calibrated so there are techniques to
recalibrate a model
so that there are some techniques to
recalibrate a model you know one of them
is called plat scaling
or you can also use something called as
a isotonic regression
so these techniques are you can think of
them as
post processing which means you fit your
model to predict the y hats what they
produce and then
you take these y hats as an input to a
new model
to learn some kind of an adjustment
factor to you know adjust y hat to be
you know an updated y hat
and that updated y hat will will be you
know better calibrated
using these techniques
but like take your loss function and
then you constantly take your slope
and then some weightage of that loss
function and some weight
so if it's close to 40 degrees
yeah so the question is you know can you
can you um
[Music]
can you kind of consider this slope and
incorporate the slope of the calibration
curve into the loss function somehow
uh so so it so happens that the the
calibration is a probability of both
your model
and the test set against which you are
measuring it so which means if you
if you train your model against in say
you know
an environment where it mostly is say
a desert like an environment and you fit
your model there and you want to know
use your model
in a different setting where you know
it's some kind of a tropical island
where the weather is very different but
you still think that your model has good
discriminative ability
of deciding rain versus not then you can
take the same model that was fit on a
different data and just recalibrate it
to
you know using these techniques to data
from you know say a tropical island
for example so you can so you may not be
you may not have access to the eventual
test set against which you want to
calibrate at the time of training
yeah so this these um these techniques
generally do not reorder the points
they just perform some kind of an
adjustment such that the ordering of the
predictions will still be the same but
your model will be calibrated yes
uh so plaque scaling is linear
isotonic regression is not linear
but they're still they still maintain
the ordering yeah this question
does changing the threshold value what
threshold of what
good question so the question is does
the uh uh threshold that we use
uh to um uh uh for the classifier
does that affect calibration the uh in
fact the answer is the other way right
so
for for calibration here we are only
plotting predicted probabilities versus
true observed frequency there's no
threshold here anywhere
right once you recalibrate your model
you will almost certainly want to choose
a new threshold
to to get a classifier out of it
yes questions
so this is not the graph to choose
thresholds this is
to to check whether the predicted
probabilities
can be thought of as probabilities
so we'll get into that probably tomorrow
or day after when we talk about
evaluation metrics about how to choose
thresholds
for now for now we're just talking about
about uh calibration yes
how often is this done in practice uh
looking at a
calibration plot oh in practice
extremely uh commonly this is done in
practice anywhere
uh you know anytime you want to take uh
uh you know
a prediction from a model and take some
action based on it
uh you know in fact you know
i would call this closer to practice
than closer to research
you know you always want to check
especially if you have
if you're constructing some kind of an
application pipeline where you take
decisions automatically based on
the model's output then you want to make
sure that your model is well calibrated
yes so uh i guess the
reason we are doing this is to uh again
maximize accuracy but accuracy in a
different way where
accuracy is not just like comparison of
our predictions
so so uh the calibration
is completely unrelated to accuracy and
let me let me show you why
um calibration you you may you may have
a perfectly so let's see this
so the question is
calibration is it equal to accuracy
right or is there any relation between
the two if your model is very accurate
should
also be calibrated if your model is
perfectly calibrated should it also be
accurate
any guesses so if if your model is
perfectly accurate should it be
calibrated any guesses
yes no okay i heard some no's and some
yeses if your model is perfectly
calibrated should it be
perfectly accurate
so so now the question is the other way
if it's perfectly calibrated
should it be accurate yeah
feels like right so the answer is no for
both
so here's an example
supposing you have you have a data set
where you have an equal number of
of you know positives and negatives and
let's say your model
assigns so probability of um
correct example let us assume
is always you know 0.51
you know just above uh above the the uh
threshold of 0.5 and probability of
wrong is equal to 0.01
now this model is perfectly accurate
it assigns a probability of 0.51 for all
the correct examples
and a probability of 0.01 for all the
wrong examples
but if you plot the calibration plot it
will be
for all the you know smallest bins it
will be close to here
but for all the examples that were at
point around 0.5
it will be here but your calibration
plot should be a straight line
right so in this example the model is
perfectly accurate but it is not
calibrated
what about the other way let's consider
again let's consider an example where
half the half the examples are positive
and half the examples are negative
and now we want to we want to ask if a
model is perfectly calibrated
is it accurate right now again you can
think of
this example where the model assigns p
of example to be equal to 0.5
for all examples
this will be perfectly calibrated right
for when for all the perfectly
for all predictions that had a 0.5 the
true frequency will be
close to 0.5 such a model will be
perfectly calibrated but will have zero
accuracy because it is assigning the
same
probability to all examples so
calibration and accuracy are kind of
you know distinct concepts they're not
they're not necessarily related to each
other yes
yeah so this alone will not tell you
whether your model is accurate or not
but this should be something that you
look at
right so generally a common thing to do
is look at
the calibration plot in relation to
the histogram of probabilities
right so take the set of all y hats and
just look at the histogram of how
your model assigns probabilities right
if your model
is well calibrated and
your histogram of probabilities look
like this
then you're in good shape right so
the model is is uh
you you call such such you know uh well
this
you know um models uh you you call such
models where you have you know a peak to
the left and peak to the right as
a model that is discriminating well you
know it's it's it's kind of sharp in its
predictions
its predictions are confident it it
either produces a
you know a very low probability or a
very high probability
and if it is calibrated then you have a
good model
right if your
if your histogram of predicted
probabilities look like this
then you know your model is not very
confident all the time
and if it's not very confident and you
know then you don't have good
discrimination power
but it may still be still be ah
calibrated
right so in in practice you want to look
you know
look at both of them simultaneously
we'll come to rocs probably tomorrow or
on friday
right all right so
calibration so now the question is uh
is there is there is there you know how
is this related to um
you know maximum entropy that we talked
about right so as
we talked ah mentioned earlier the
maximum entropy principle tells us that
the choice of the probability
distribution that we estimate
should be as uncertain as possible
subject to some constraints that we have
and that will naturally lead
to probability estimates that are well
calibrated
why is that let's see so
ah
so maximum entropy
we saw earlier leads to
maximum likelihood right so maximum
entropy implied maximum
likelihood and in maximum likelihood
what we
the objective of interest is this
right so ah
in mle we did
right so if x is the is the um
is the predicted probability then what
we do is
ah we use log p of x or the negative
log p of x as the loss
right so you know loss with respect to
theta right
we use this as the loss now to
understand
the the connection between calibration
and mle or maximum entropy we want to
rethink the the notion of loss function
a little bit
slightly right generally we think of
loss function as a function between
y and y hat where y
is the is the observed or the ground
truth or the correct answer and y hat is
our prediction
right however to kind of get a better
understanding of
of calibration you want to instead think
of this
scoring rule
so scoring rule that takes two inputs
a probability a
function p hat and y
so y is still the true observed
observed outcome and p hat is our
predicted probability distribution
right p hat is not a point estimate but
it's a predicted probability
distribution
it so happens that in logistic
regression
the single point estimate probability
defines the full probability
distribution
but in general ah you know
if if you if you are for example in a
regression setting
think of this to be a full gaussian
distribution like the mean and variance
of a full gaussian distribution for
example
right so this is
a probability distribution
over all possible outcomes
right and this is
the
the actual observed outcome
right so our model
will output p hat a full probability
distribution or all possible outcomes
so if if we if we are you know some kind
of uh uh you know in
a weather forecasting setting for
example this will
uh give a probable and let's say we are
trying to
to measure say wind speed of tomorrow
for example then this will give you uh
a probability distribution that it's
going to be
have a five percent probability that the
wind will be you know
10 miles per hour seven percent
probability that the wind
speed will be you know 15 miles per hour
and so on it's going to give you a full
probability distribution
over the entire outcome space right in
case of a binary decision of whether
it's going to rain tomorrow or not if
the outcomes are only two
if all what you care is will it rain or
not train you don't care how much it
rains
if that's the space of outcomes then
the outcome is you know 30 percent that
it will rain
and therefore 70 percent that it will
not rain or 50 percent that it will rain
and therefore 50
it will not rain so it's the it's a full
probability distribution over the space
of outcomes
we are not assuming a bayesian setting
all we that we have is
you know some predicted probability
distribution and one observed outcome
right and and the next day will again
output a full probability distribution
and there will be some one observed
outcome
the the uh the difference between
bayesian and and uh frequentist is how
we treat the parameters
here this is just you know predictions
right
um yeah this this is this is not
bayesian versus
frequent this is this more general
so now
we we have this notion of what is called
as
a proper scoring rule
a proper scoring rule is one that
satisfies
this requirement so let us call a proper
scoring rule
let us call it f
so f is a proper scoring rule if it
satisfies
so ah proper scoring rule f where
f takes a probability distribution
an outcome and maps it to a real value
right a scoring rule is one that takes
the observation made by a forecaster and
then observes the actual outcome
looks at those two and assigns a score
of how well the forecaster did
right you want to think of the scoring
rule that way so it takes a prediction
a full probability distribution one
observed outcome and assigns a score
right and the a proper scoring rule is
one
that satisfies
q
you
so a proper scoring rule f
is that scoring rule which satisfies
this inequality that
the expectation of f of q comma y
where y is sampled according to q
is less than equal to expectation of
f of p comma y y sample to q
for all p and q and you call it
a strictly proper scoring rule
strictly proper
scoring rule where
equality implies p equals q
right what what does this mean
so let's let's let's uh try to to
understand this a little better so we
have
we have you know uh two two uh
you know two instances of the uh scoring
rule being
uh a call
the scoring rule as i said takes a
prediction and an actual outcome
right prediction and an actual outcome
f is a proper scoring rule if
when the actual outcomes follow a
distribution
q actual outcomes follow some
distribution q
the average score assigned by
f for a prediction
q itself where q was how the actual y's
were distributed
will be less than the
average score assigned by f where the
prediction was a different
uh distribution p than how y was
actually distributed
right now if f is used as a loss
function
for your model and f is a proper scoring
rule
then your models will tend to be well
calibrated
why is that that's because the the uh
the the proper scoring the proper
scoring rule
naturally rewards q
to have the best possible score when q
was the distribution according to which
y's
were getting observed from right
so y y tilde q here and
and and y tilde q you want to think of
this as
you know q being the way the weather is
actually modeled
and y's are therefore sampled according
to the way the weather is actually
um happening in in real life and
the the probability distribution that's
passed to f is the prediction
that we are making right the best
possible prediction
is when we predict the true uh weather
itself
as our prediction right for any other
prediction
which is not the actual weather
you know the actual weather then it will
get a worse
score according to the problem according
to this scoring rule
if this satisfies for all p and q then f
is a proper scoring rule
this question
so so here you can think of this as loss
a higher loss is worse so
we want f to assign you know low values
for better predictions
right yeah i'm going to come to that
right
right so this is a proper scoring rule
right now from this
you know you you you know it's it's uh
it's easy to see that
if we recover you know
if we recover the best possible
prediction
then our model is naturally calibrated
because the best possible prediction is
q itself
right so the best possible prediction
that we can do is to predict q
because you know that is the lowest loss
that can be attained
and so you know using
proper scoring rules as our loss
functions
will encourage our models to be better
calibrated
does that make sense any other
any other other other
any other p other than q will
attain a low a worse loss compared to
predicting q itself
and when you compare you know when you
predict q itself
your calibration curve will be a
straight line because
um depending on
you know if if y's are sampled from q
such that it is eighty percent
you know eighty percent then um
we want to predict eighty percent uh
and and that would be the the um because
that's
that's the best thing to do according to
the scoring rule
does that make sense yes from this it
seems like are getting at the
distribution at which y is being
distributed
which implies accuracy right this does
not
necessarily imply accuracy so so the
question is you know
uh you know does this imply accuracy it
need not because
what we are looking for is you know the
average scores
in long term so supposing it rains 50 uh
on average
right uh your predictions
uh may be such that you know half the
time you predicted it will rain but half
the time you will
predict it will not rain and in the long
running average you know you may match
the frequencies but on every given day
you maybe end up predicting the wrong
thing
right so this is not related to accuracy
right so a proper scoring rule will
encourage your your
uh your model to have the long
run um um long run
frequency match the predicted frequency
or the predicted probability and now the
question is
and now the question is how is this
related to maximum entropy so first
first do we have do we have a consensus
on this that if we employ a proper
scoring rule
because of this property of of proper
scoring rules
the predicted probabilities will tend to
be calibrated
or is there a question on that yes
the loss function question took just the
y and y hat if you had like
if you took the theta this which was
from the data generating process
then also it will have a better estimate
over the
predicted theta so why not use that
directly because it also follows the
same
inequality i'm sorry i i i i didn't
translate this question
in that like the last function y was
from a data generating process and when
we calculate y hat we
make an estimate of our theta even in
that
case our inequality was the same the
loss would be less than our
given loss what do you mean by y hat
you wrote about scoring rule on the left
side
you have the same inequality well may or
may not right so
so the question is if if we use a loss
value uh
like this where y hat was just theta
transpose x um
will we get the same inequality so in
case of logistic regression
y hat completely determined the entire
distribution
but in case of regression that's not the
case if you just have a point estimate
it's not
a distribution over all the possible y's
right so in case of logistic regression
you know y hat
or the point estimate of the probability
is the full distribution
right but it's that's not the case in
more general settings like you know
regression
right so now the question is ah so
assuming that we have a consensus that
employing a proper scoring rule
encourages our model
uh encourages us to recover the true
probability distribution in which case
you know the models will tend to be
calibrated now the question is how is
this related to maximum entropy
so in maximum entropy
we saw that maximum entropy gives rise
to
mle and mle is essentially
ah this mle the
loss is y coming from
q and
minus log
one over p
right so this is the ah you know
so this is the uh
the loss or you know let's think of this
as like the true loss
so this is the true loss of a maximum
likelihood
where y is distributed according to some
you know data generating distribution
and the loss that we have is the
negative log likelihood
or so sorry this should be log p hat
right so the model predicts p hat but
the data is
distributed according to y the loss is
the
negative log likelihood under the
expectation
where y hat you know is is
distributed according to q now
what remains to be showed is
this is a proper scoring rule
right so
minus not p hat of y sorry
so y's are are the zeros and ones they
are sampled according to q
and p hat is is a lot p hat of y so p
hat is the
generated uh is the predicted
probability
and we want to evaluate y according to
this right so
what remains to be showed is this is a
proper scoring rule
and the way we show this as a proper
scoring rule is
pretty simple we want to show
this inequality right so expectation of
y according to q
minus log q of y
should be less than or equal to
expectation of
y according to q of
minus log p of y
right and
we take this to the right hand side
and this you know we get 0 or
we take
we want to show this is uh less than
this yeah
so we take um
it's greater than equal to 0 yeah so we
take this to the right hand side and we
get
is equal to expectation y
according to q
log
so this is minus log so this when it
comes here it will be a plus log
you get log q of y
over b and this is negative so this is 1
over p over
p y so we need to show this and this can
be easily shown because this is just the
kl divergence between q and p and that's
always non-negative
right so
the maximum entropy principle
is equivalent to maximum likelihood
estimate
estimation and the maximum likelihood
estimation
uses negative log as the proper scoring
rule
as the as the loss function and this
loss function
due to kl divergence being non-negative
implies that it's a proper scoring rule
and because its a proper scoring rule
the estimated probabilities will tend to
be well calibrated
right so that that is like you know the
multi step connection between
maximum entropy and calibration
right so maximizing entropy is is
therefore
uh therefore leads
to your model being well calibrated
yes questions
so this is the loss function that you've
been using for logistic regression
this is the same thing that you've been
using for logistic regression it's no
different
is there anything different
yes this is the cross entropy loss and
that is the same as the maximum
likelihood estimation it's the same loss
you can you can work out the math there
and they're exactly the same
right there are other kinds of entropy
measures that you can use
so here we used you know uh for maximum
entropy we used you know the shannon's
entropy that's you know
p lock p there are different kinds of
entropies uh that are um
that are there not just i know shannon's
entropy and by using a different kind of
an entropy you get different kinds of a
divergence rather than kl divergence and
you get a different loss function
and all those will still be um
will will lead to calibration models as
long as the scoring rule that you get
is a proper scoring rule that's that's
the uh general uh
general takeaway in this all right uh so
we're out of time and we'll start with
the em variants
and and uh the variational auto encoder
in the next class
right thanks